THIS CALIFORNIA STATE SENATORS
JANUARY FOURTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO WELL THE SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ARCHULETA.
ATKINS FATE PORGES BRADFORD CUT
BY ADAM CORTESE DALLY DODD THERE
ARE ALSO EGGMAN GLAZER GROVE
HURTS BERG WEST SO HER TADO
JONES CAN LONGER LAYERED LIMO
OWN MCGUIRE MELINDA'S NEWMAN
NIELSEN A TRAIL OF BOTH. CAN
FORTY TINO ROSSI RUBIO SKINNER
AMBERG WHITE HOUSE SKI WINNER
WELK. THANK YOU VERY MUCH A
QUORUM IS PRESENT PRESENT A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS BEYOND
THE RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY
PLEASE RISE WE WILL BE LED IN
PRAYER THIS MORNING BY SENATOR
BRADFORD AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WILL BE LED THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. BY SENATOR WIENER LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN IF YOU CAN PLEASE
GIVE OUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR
BRADFORD. SENATOR BRADFORD THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT. WE'RE TIED
TOGETHER IN A SINGLE GARMENT OF
DESTINY. CAUGHT IN AN
INESCAPABLE NETWORK OF MUTUALITY
WHATEVER AFFECTS ONE DIRECTLY
AFFECTS ALL INDIRECTLY THESE
WERE THE WORDS OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING IN A LETTER FROM A
BIRMINGHAM JAIL APRIL SIXTEENTH
NINETEEN SIXTY THREE. MERCIFUL
AND COMPASSIONATE GOD. THESE
WORDS OF ROBIN DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING RESONATE WITH US AS WE
REMEMBER AND CELEBRATE THE LIFE
AND LEGACY OF DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING. BE WITH US THIS YEAR AS WE
WORK IN SOLIDARITY WITH EACH
OTHER. ADDING OUR VOICES TO THE
VOICES OF THOSE WHO STILL
STRUGGLE DAILY FOR JUSTICE AND
EQUALITY. MAY WE RECOGNIZE AND
RESPOND TO THE FIERCE URGENCY OF
NOW. AS WE ENCOUNTER CRISIS UPON
CRISIS AND ARE MOVING TOWARD
LOVING ONE ANOTHER. HELP US
UNDERSTAND THAT IN THIS TIME WE
ARE INTERCALL TO HOPING BIRTH
THE FUTURE FROM THE CRUCIBLE OF
THE PAST AND THE PRESENT.
GRACIOUS GOD AS WE INTENSIFY OUR
DESIRE TO LIVE WITH INTEGRITY OF
WORD AND DEED HELP US CONTINUE
TO GROW INTO THAT NETWORK OF
MUTUALITY THERE FOR JUST OUR
UNITY AND BRINGS US. TO HONOR
THE LIFE AND TIMES OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING A MAN. THE COLORS
PLEASE REMAIN THE PLEDGE OF
ALLEGIANCE I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE
TO THE FLAG. THIS. THANK YOU
MEMBERS AND GUESTS TODAY WE HAVE
SENATORS BECKER GONZALEZ LEIVA
MEN AND STERN PARTICIPATING
REMOTELY GOOD MORNING SENATORS.
THE SET THIS MORNING MESSAGES
FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED
READ MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY
WILL BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEE WILL BE DEEMED RED.
MEMBERS GONNA MOVE TO MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES CENTERS
IF YOU HAVE ANY MEASURES TO
REMOVE FROM THE NECK TO FILE NOW
IS THE TIME TO ASK FOR THAT TO
BE DONE. THE CENTRE RUBY ARE YOU
ASKING ME RECOGNISED SENT REVIEW
. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT PLEASE
REMOVE ALL ITEMS EIGHT NINE S.
B. SEVENTY AND PLACE ON THIRD
READING FILE PLEASE REMOVE FILE
ITEM EIGHT ELEVEN THAT'S SP FIVE
SIXTY AND PLACE ON THE THIRD
READING FILE THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SAY OKAY WE'RE GONNA GO TO
SECOND READING FILE SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. I'M SORRY HOLD ON.
THE MISCOMMUNICATION APPEAR ON
THE DIALYSIS CENTER REVEAL THOSE
WILL GO TO SECOND READING THAT
WE'RE ASKING FOR. YES YES THANK
YOU OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH ANY
OTHER MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS
ITEMS TO BE PULLED OR OTHER
BUSINESS FROM THE SENATOR SHOWS
THIS MORNING. SEEING NONE- WE
ARE GOING TO GO INTO
INTRODUCTIONS AND FIRST READING
OF BILLS BILLS WILL BE DENIED
READ. WE'RE GONNA MOVE TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE
SECOND READING FILES SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. ASSEMBLY BILL SIX
SIX SIX. THANK YOU NEXT WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE TO SENATE THIRD
READING WE HAVE ONE ITEM ON
SENATE THIRD READING WHICH IS
ITEM FORTY FOUR AND I BELIEVE
THAT. CENTER BRADFORD'S TAKING
THAT UP IS THAT CORRECT. YOUR
RECORD AT SIX FIFTY THREE SENATE
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION SIXTY TWO
BY SENATOR BRADFORD RELATIVE TO
REVEREND DOCTOR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
I STAND BEFORE YOU AS AUTHOR OF
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
SIXTY TWO AS IN HONOR OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR ASSURE
THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS. I
STAND IN FRONT OF THIS GREAT
BODY IN SOLIDARITY WITH MICE
FELLOW SENATOR AND FELLOW SEAL
B. C. MEMBER AND VICE CHAIR
SENATOR. TOM LOGGER TO RECOGNIZE
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR WHO
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO NON
VIOLENT STRUGGLE FOR RACIAL
EQUALITY IN UNITED STATES AND
ABROAD. THE LATE DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING WAS BORN ON JANUARY
FIFTEENTH NINETEEN TWENTY NINE
IN ATLANTA GEORGIA. THIS YEAR
WOULD HAVE BEEN DR KING'S NINETY
THIRD BIRTHDAY AND WE WERE
HONORED TO HAVE. HIS COLLEAGUE
REVEREND LAWSON WHO IS
CELEBRATING NINETY THREE YEARS
OF. STRUGGLE AND CONTINUE TO
FIGHT WITH US THIS PAST
WEDNESDAY AT THE MARTIN LUTHER
KING CELEBRATION. IT'S BEEN
NEARLY FIFTY FORTY YEARS SINCE
DR KING WAS ASSASSINATED ON
APRIL FOURTH NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. IN MEMPHIS TENNESSEE. DR
KING CHARLES WORK DURING THE
CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT WAS
INSTRUMENTAL IN THE PASSAGE OF
THE LANDMARK CIVIL RIGHTS ACT OF
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR THE VOTING
RIGHTS ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY
FIVE. DR MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS
A COURAGEOUS MAN WHO DID NOT
SIMPLY TALK THE TALK BUT WAS
WILLING TO DIE. BY HIS MORALS
AND HIS CONVICTION. WITHOUT DR
KING'S DETERMINATION RESILIENCE
I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO SERVE
HERE IN THIS POSITION AND I SAID
AS I STAND HERE TODAY IN FRONT
OF EACH AND EVERYONE OF YOU.
NEITHER WOULD PROBABLY MANY OF
MY COLLEAGUES IN THE LEGISLATIVE
BLACK CAUCUS. DR KING'S COURAGE
AND RESILIENCE HAS INSPIRED AND
MOTIVATED GENERATIONS OF
INDIVIDUALS WORLDWIDE. AND MANY
LIKE ME TO GROW UP WHO GREW UP
DURING THE CIVIL RIGHTS
MOVEMENT. ONE ZERO WE HAD THE
PLEASURE AGAIN OF HOSTING THE
BLACK CAUCUSES M. OKAY BREAKFAST
AND I HOPE WE WERE ALL LEFT
INSPIRED BY THOSE WHO CAME TO
JOIN US IN HONORING THE WORK OF
THIS GREAT MAN. AND STATED WE
WERE JOINED BY REVEREND LAWSON
WHO WAS AS DR KING'S RIGHT HAND
MAN DURING MOST OF THE
STRUGGLES. FOR CIVIL RIGHTS IN
THIS COUNTRY. AND IF YOU MISS IT
I ASKED YOU TO CHECK OUT
FACEBOOK OVER THE HOLIDAY
WEEKEND AND I PROMISE YOU YOU
WILL BE BY WHAT WAS
THERE. AS REFLECT ON HIGH WE HE
PERMANENTLY CHANGE OUR COUNTRY
WITH HIS IDEALS WE MUST REMEMBER
THAT THIS. VISION IS NOT YET
COMPLETE. TO TRULY PAID TRIBUTE
TO THE LIFE AND WORK OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR. AND
ALL THAT HE HAS DONE TO.
MATERIALIZE HIS VISION OF HAVING
A MORE JUST AND EQUAL SOCIETY.
WE MUST. HAVE THE WILL AND
APPETITE TO DO THE RIGHT THING.
DOCTOR KING ONCE SAID THE TIME
IS ALWAYS RIGHT. TO DO WHAT IS
RIGHT. CALLING TO TIME TO DO
WHAT'S RIGHT IS NOW OUR
DEMOCRACY OUR STATE OUR NATION
DEPENDS ON IT. IT IS NOT ENOUGH
FOR YOU ALONE TO GET INTO SOME
GOOD TROUBLE WE ALL NEED TO GET
INTO GOOD TROUBLE. WE HAVE TO
GALVANIZE AND EMPOWER OUR
FAMILIES FRIENDS AND COMMUNITIES
TO JOIN US IN THIS EFFORT. WE
MUST HONOR DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING'S LEGACY WHAT ACTION WITH
VOTES AND SPEAKING TRUTH TO
POWER. IT IS OUR MANDATE TO HIS
LEGACY TO CREATE POSITIVE CHANGE
WHICH TAKES US CLOSER STEP BY
STEP TO REALIZING CIVIL RIGHTS
SOCIAL JUSTICE IN CALIFORNIA AND
OUR NATION IS NOT ENOUGH NEW
BOOK HIS WORDS AND HIS NAME AND
DO ABSOLUTELY NOTHING. THE NIGHT
BEFORE DR MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS
ASSASSINATED HE AND HIS FELLOW.
COMRADES RAYMOND JAMES LAWSON
WERE IN TOWN TO HELP ORGANIZE A
STRIKE FOR THIRTEEN HUNDRED
BLOCK SANITATION WORKERS ELEVEN
DAYS AFTER TO MEMPHIS GARBAGE
COLLECTORS APPLE COLE AND ROBERT
WALKER WERE CRUSHED TO DEATH IN
A MANUFACTURING TRUCK. DR KING'S
LAST SPEECH I'VE BEEN TO THE
MOUNTAINTOP HE SAID WE GOT TO
GIVE OURSELVES TO THIS STRUGGLE
UNTIL THE END NOTHING WOULD BE
MORE TRAGIC THAN TO STOP AT THIS
POINT IN MEMPHIS. WE GOT TO SEE
THIS THROUGH. I ASKED LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN ARE YOU PREPARED TO
SEE THIS FIGHT THROUGH. THE
FIGHT NOT ONLY TO RESTORE OUR
DEMOCRACY WE HAVE COME TO KNOW
BUT TO ENVISION A DEMOCRACY FOR
ALL MEN AND WOMEN REGARDLESS OF
COLOR RACE CREED ARE. TREATED
EQUAL N. AFFORDED THE FULL
PROMISE OF THIS COUNTRY I
BELIEVE DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
WOULD WANT US TO MAKE A
DETERMINED. FOR TEN DURING ANY
AND ALL CHALLENGES IF IT MEANT
REALIZING THE DREAM FOR FUTURE
GENERATIONS AS LAWMAKERS
CITIZENS AND THIS NATION. I
ASSURE YOU THE LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS IT'S TIME TO SEE THIS
FIGHT FOR EQUALITY AND JUSTICE
THROUGH I HOPE YOU WILL JOIN US
IN THIS EFFORT BY COMING
TOGETHER TO HONOR DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING AND BY FIGHTING.
WILL KEEP HIS DREAM ALIVE I
RESPECT US FOR I VOTE ON S. C.
R. SIXTY TWO. THANK YOU SENATOR
BRADFORD I WOULD LIKE TO
UNDERSCORE. AND ENCOURAGE THOSE
MEMBERS THAT DIDN'T GET A CHANCE
TO PARTICIPATE ON WEDNESDAY
MORNING TO GO BACK AND WATCH IT
WAS VERY ENCOURAGING. REVEREND
LAWSON- THE GREAT MAN OF WISDOM
THAT I'VE NEVER MET BEFORE AND-
I WAS VERY ENCOURAGED BY HIS
CHECK COMMENTS ON WEDNESDAY
MORNING THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD.
CENTER PAN YOU'RE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT SENATORS
I TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF
THIS YOU ARE SIXTY TWO AND A
HALF AS CHAIR OF THE ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER LEGISLATIVE
CAUCUS. I'M HONORED TO RICE TO
CELEBRATE THE LIFE OF DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING. DR KING FOUGHT FOR
INCLUSIVE INCLUSIVITY AND
EQUALITY AND FACTORS- MY GOOD
FRIEND- FROM LOS ANGELES SAID
MANY OF US. WILL PROBABLY NOT
EVEN BE SERVING HERE IN THIS
CHAMBER IT WAS NOT FOR HIS
LEADERSHIP. CIVIL RIGHTS LEADERS
LIKE DR KING ARE THE REASON WE
HAVE MANY OF THE RIGHTS WE ENJOY
TODAY. N. ARE THE INSPIRATION
FOR CONTINUING TO FIGHT. TO
ACHIEVE EQUALITY EQUAL RIGHTS
FOR EVERY AMERICAN. MANY ASIAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUTERS
BELIEVING CONTINUE BELIEVE AND
MARTIN LUTHER KING'S DREAM. FEW
EXAMPLES GRACE LEE BOGGS
COLLABORATED WITH DOCTOR CAME TO
ORGANIZED IN NINETEEN SIXTY
THREE WHAT THE FREEDOM IN
DETROIT AND RICHARD OKEY OF THE
ASIAN AMERICAN POLITICAL SCIENCE
WHO JOINED CHARLIE BROWN OF THE
AMERICAN AFRICAN AMERICAN
STUDENT UNION. AND MANUEL
DELGADO THE MEXICAN AMERICAN
STUDENT CONFEDERATION BELIEVED
TO LEAD THE THIRD WORLD
LIBERATION FRONT IN NINETEEN
SIXTY EIGHT. CERTAINLY RECOGNIZE
LEADERSHIP AND SACRIFICE OF
BLACK AMERICANS. TO ACHIEVE A
MORE JUST AND EQUITABLE. AMERICA
AND THE AMA ASIAN AMERICAN
PACIFIC ISLANDER COMMUNITY
STANDS IN SOLIDARITY LAST YEAR
WE EXPERIENCED IN THE SPIKE IN
ANTI ASIAN HATE CRIMES WE KNOW
THAT WELL CERTAINLY OUR
COMMUNITY DID EXPERIENCE THIS
THAT WAS NOT SOLELY LIMITED TO.
ASIAN AMERICANS THAT ACTUALLY
ALL COMMUNITY COLOR EXPERIENCE
INCREASE HEY. AND WE APPRECIATE
THE SOLIDARITY OF US WORKING
TOGETHER TO STOP HATE AGAINST
OUR COMMUNITIES. MARTIN LUTHER
KING AN INSPIRATION TO ALL
AMERICANS PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SUPPORTING S. C. R. SIXTY TWO
AND COMMIT TO CONTINUING TO WORK
. IN MAKING MARTIN LUTHER KING'S
DREAM INTO A REALITY THERE'S
MUCH WORK TO DO. I STAND IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF S. R. SIXTY
TWO THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR
PANEL GO TO SENATOR EDMUND
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR SKINNER
CENTER AT. THANK YOU- I AM PROUD
TO RISE ON BEHALF OF S. C. R.
SIXTY TWO ON BEHALF OF THE LGBT
CAUCUS. WE ALL KNOW WHAT DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING DEAD AND HE'S
BEEN A PERSONAL HERO CERTAINLY
FOR ME AND FOR MANY IN THIS ROOM
AND AS IS ALREADY BEEN STATED
MANY OF US WOULDN'T HAVE BEEN
HERE. WITHOUT THE STAND HE TOOK.
ON THE MOVEMENT HE HELPED CREATE
AND CERTAINLY HELP SHEPHERD.
INTO ALL OF OUR REALIZATIONS. I
THINK SOMETIMES WE FORGET ABOUT
THE CONTEXT IN WHICH ALL OF THAT
OCCURRED. THERE WAS ANOTHER A
DEATH THIS WEEK OF A AT ANOTHER
OF HIS CITY PORT J. AND I DON'T
KNOW IF ANY OF YOU I GREW UP
WATCHING SIDNEY PORTIER MOVIES
AND LOVING THEM. EVER WATCHING
WITH WITH AUDREY. IN THE BEAUTY-
AND FOR MANY PEOPLE IT WAS THE
FIRST TIME WE HAD SEEN AN
AFRICAN AMERICAN ACTOR AS AN
EQUAL ON THE SCREEN WITH
EVERYBODY ELSE NOT PLAYING A
SUBSERVIENT ROLE. AND I THOUGHT
ABOUT THAT AND I WATCH THIS I
REMEMBER WATCHING IT WITH MY
THIRTEEN YEAR ALL EYES AND THEN
I WATCHED IT WITH MY DAUGHTER
WITH HER THIRTEEN YEAR OLD I.
AND AS A AS A YOUNG CHILD- OF
COLOR. IN AND HAVING TO EXPLAIN
TO HER ONE YOU SAW I MEAN CITY
FORTUNE WAS SO FAMOUS BECAUSE HE
WAS ABLE TO HOLD. HIS GRADES HE
WAS ABLE TO NOT REACT. AS THE
ONLY ONE WHO WAS IN A IN A
SITUATION AS THE AS IF THE FIRST
AND THE ONLY WHEN HE WAS. EITHER
IS IT BECAUSE- YOU KNOW THEY
CALL ME SIR OR CALL ME MISTER
TIBBS. ALL OF THOSE FILMS. WHERE
WE SAW THAT HE WOULD JUST. TAKE
AN INSULT. AND NOT REACT. BUT
CERTAINLY NOT LET IT BE OKAY.
AND THAT WAS THE CONTEXT IN
WHICH DR MARTIN LUTHER KING WAS
DOING THIS ORGANIZING. WERE FOR
SO MANY IT WAS A PLACE THEY
COULDN'T EVEN BEGIN TO IMAGINE.
BUT FOR SO MANY WHO WERE BRAVE
WHO KNOWS- EQUALITY WAS WAS
BETTER FOR ALL OF US. THAT
AWARENESS AND VISIBILITY WAS
BETTER FOR ALL OF US AT THE MORE
INTEGRATED WE COULD BE. THEN THE
MORE THAT WE COULD SEE THAT WE
ARE SO MORE. ALIKE THAN WE ARE
DIFFERENT. AND THAT'S WHAT DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING STOOD FOR
RIGHT THAT WE CAN ALL HAVE OUR
PLACE THAT WE CAN ALL BE SEEN
THAT IT IS NOT SCARY. FOR US TO
BE DIFFERENT. HE WAS A REVERENT
OF JUSTICE VERSUS A REVERENT OF.
EXCLUSION HE WAS SOMEONE WHO.
TAUGHT US ABOUT THAT IDEAL AND
TRY TO LEAD US TO JUSTICE.
RATHER THAN LEADING US INTO
DIVISION INTO OUR CORNERS. IF WE
CAN REMEMBER ANYTHING AS WE
HONOR HIS BIRTH. TO REMEMBER HIS
LEGACY. AND REMEMBER THE CONTEXT
IN THE BRAVERY IT TOOK DURING
THAT TIME. TO CONTINUE TO SAY.
WE ARE ALL THE SAME. AND UNTIL
WE ALL LINK ARMS AND MOVE
FORWARD TOGETHER WILL REMAIN
DIVIDED AND ANGRY IN OUR CORNERS
SO LET US TAKE NEW HEART TODAY.
AS WE KNOW THE PROGRESS WE'VE
SEEN THE PROGRESS WE LOOK BACK
IN TIME YOU CAN SEE THE PROGRESS
AND WE KNOW THAT THERE'S STILL
SO MUCH MORE TO GO. AS WE
CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE WITH OUR
OWN IDENTITIES AS AMERICANS. LET
US INTEGRATE DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING'S WORDS AND HIS VISION AND
ALL OF THOSE WHO CRAVE TO BE
VISIBLE AND TAKE THEIR RIGHTFUL
PLACE. SO THAT WE CAN TRULY
CREATE THAT GARMENT. THAT WRAPS
US ALL IN ITS DESTINY I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. ON S. C. R. SIXTY TWO
. AND ADMIN S. INNER SCANNER
WILL BE FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
WIENER SENATOR SKINNER. THANK
YOU FIVE MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS I
RISE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS IN SUPPORT OF S.
C. R. SIXTY TWO. DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING WAS NOT A ONE
DIMENSIONAL LEADER. HE
UNDERSTOOD THAT THE STRUGGLE FOR
CIVIL RIGHTS AND EQUALITY WAS
MULTI DIMENSIONAL THAT IT WAS
INTERSECTIONAL. FULLY
INTERSECTION WITH THE STRUGGLE
FOR FULL HUMAN RIGHTS ECONOMIC.
JUSTICEECONOMIC EQUALITY WORKER
DIGNITY AND JUSTICE WITHIN OUR
CRIMINAL IN PORCHESTER. HE WAS
AN INNOVATOR OF NONVIOLENT
MOVEMENT BUILDING AND HIS
LEADERSHIP WAS PIVOTAL DURINGA
DIFFICULT TIME IN OUR NATION A
TIME WHERE WE WERE OUR COUNTRY
IS EXPERIENCING GREAT SOCIAL
UPHEAVAL WHEN WE FACED A LOT OF
CONTRADICTIONS IT IS VERY
SIMILAR TO TODAY. ONE OF THE
GREAT MARKS OF HIS LEADERSHIP
WAS HIS FIERCE URGENCY. AND ONE
OF THE QUOTES OF HIS THAT I HAVE
ALWAYS BEEN. IT IS NOT JUST%
INSPIRED BY BUT MOTIVATED EACH
DAY BYE WAS WHEN H SAID WE ARE
NOW FACED WITH THE FACT THAT
TOMORROW IS TODAY WE ARE
CONFRONTED WITH THE FIERCE
URGENCY OF NOW. IN THIS
UNFOLDING CONUNDRUM OF LIFE IN
HISTORY THERE IS SUCH A THING AS
BEING TOO LATE THERE IS NO TIME
FOR APATHY OR COMPLACENCY THIS
IS A TIME FOR VIGOROUS AND
POSITIVE ACTION. AS WE HONOR DR
KING I HOPE THAT WE HEED THOSE
WORDS AND THAT WE COMMIT
OURSELVES TO VIGOROUS AND
POSITIVE ACTION. FOR CIVIL
RIGHTS VOTING RIGHTS.
ENVIRONMENTAL AND ECONOMIC
JUSTICE AND GENDER AND RACIAL
EQUITY. AND THAT WE MEET THE
URGENCY OF NOW SO THAT WE MAKE
EACH DAY WORTHY OF DR KING'S
DREAM AND I THINK ALL OF OUR
DREAMS. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR SKINNER GO TO CENTER
WINNER FOLLOWED BY CENTER
GONZALEZ ONLINE- CENTER WINNER.
I THANK YOU- MR PRESIDENT I-
RISE AS VICE CHAIR OF THE JEWISH
LEGISLATIVE JEWISH CAUCUS IN
SUPPORT OF A ZERO SIXTY TWO- THE
JEWISH COMMUNITY- AND VARIOUS
RABBIS AND OTHER JEWISH LEADERS.
I PLAYED A ROLE IN THE CIVIL
RIGHTS MOVEMENT SUPPORTING DR
KING AND THE MOVEMENT GENERALLY-
THERE WERE JEWS WHO LOST THEIR
LIVES IN THE SOUTH- AS PART OF
THAT MOVEMENT STANDING IN
SOLIDARITY. WITH OUR BLACK
BROTHERS AND SISTERS- AND THIS
IS- IN RELATIONSHIP TO THE BLACK
COMMUNITY AND THE JEWISH
COMMUNITY IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT ONE- THROUGHOUT SO
MANY DIFFERENT- CIVIL RIGHTS
STRUGGLES. ON IT'S ALSO- ALWAYS
IMPORTANT TO REMEMBER THAT
DESPITE THE COMMON MISPERCEPTION
THAT- THE JEWISH COMMUNITY IS
ENTIRELY WHITE THAT'S NOT TRUE A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER O JEWS OF
COLOR PARTICULARLY A SIGNIFICANT
NUMBER OF. A BLACK SHOES AND
SERVICE THESE COMMUNITIES- I
HAVE INCREDIBLE- OVERLAP AND WE
ALWAYS HAVE TO STAND IN
SOLIDARITY WITH ONE ANOTHER- AND
THAT OF COURSE CONTINUES TODAY.
AS WE CONTINUE TO WORK- TO
UNRAVEL AND STRUCTURAL RACISM IN
THIS COUNTRY. WHETHER IT'S
ENDING MASS INCARCERATION-
WHETHER IT IS PREVENTING- THE
REOCCURRENCE OF INCREDIBLE- WITH. EXTRA TENS OF BUT-
UNFORTUNATELY AROUND THE
COUNTRY. AND IS A TO CPAS TO IN
FRANCE. BLACK PEOPLE ARE FROM.
VOTING IT'S NOT A QUICK. THAT
WHEN WE LOOK AT- WHERE THE
ATTACKS ON VOTING RIGHTS IN THE%
TWENTY TWENTY ELECTION HAPPENED-
THE ATTACKS AND ACCUSATIONS WERE
IN WHITE COMMUNITIES IT WAS IN
BLACK COMMUNITIES IN PLACES LIKE
PHILADELPHIA. OR CLEVELAND OR-
OTHER AREAS WHERE WE HAVE A
SIGNIFICANT BLACK COMMUNITY- SO
WE NEED TO ALWAYS KEEP THAT IN
MIND AND REMEMBER THAT DR KING'S
WORK IS NOT EVEN CLOSE TO BEING
DONE THANK YOU. THANK YOU SIR WE
ARE GOING TO CENTER GONZALEZ
REMOTELY FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
COME LONGER CENTER GONZALEZ.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT- I TOO
WANTED TO STREAM REMOTELY. AND
SUPPORT S. T. R. SIXTY TWO BY
SENATOR- THE GOOD SENATOR FROM
GARDENA- AS WE TAKE THIS LONG
WEEKEND TO PONDER THE LEGACY OF
THE LATE- DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
IT IS ALWAYS IMPORTANT TO KNOW
THAT HE WASN'T JUST A CIVIL
RIGHTS LEADER. FOR ALL BUT FOR
SPECIALLY FOR THE LATINO
COMMUNITY- THE LATINO COMMUNITY
ACTUALLY DROVE OUT MANY
PROTESTERS AS WE ALL KNOW ON
BEHALF OF AT FARM WORKER RIGHTS
AND IMMIGRATION- LED BY SISTER
CHAVEZ AND DELORES WENT BACK AND
THEY ACTUALLY FOLLOWED THE-
INCREDIBLE MODEL OF DR KING. AND
THIS IS IN MY OPINION AND
LEARNING FROM FROM MANY
EDUCATORS AND IN LONG BEACH AS
STATED IN IN IN HIGH SCHOOL. AS
MY FIRST EXAMPLE OF THE
BLACKGROUND SOLIDARITY THAT
WE'VE SEEN- THAT HAS RESONATED
FOR MANY MANY DECADES THROUGHOUT
THE YEARS AND THAT WE'VE SEEN SO
PRIVATE- PREVALENCE NOW AS WE
SEE SO MANY MOVEMENTS THAT THAT
HAPPENED- IN THE MOST RECENT
TIMES. AND HIS INSPIRATION CAN
STILL BE DRAWN ON TODAY AS THE
FIGHT FOR ECONOMIC AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE CONTINUES NOT JUST FOR
LATINOS BUT AS MANY OF MY
COLLEAGUES MENTIONS FOR SO MANY.
AMERICANS AND WE WILL CONTINUE
TO BE IN SOLIDARITY. WITH NON
VIOLENT PROTESTS AND HE HE
CERTAINLY DID SO ON THE STRATEGY
BASED ON GANDHI OFFER INTO
INDIA'S INDEPENDENCE FROM. THE
BRITISH EMPIRE DECADES BEFORE
AND THIS IS THIS NONVIOLENT
PROTEST. IN THE- SUPPORTING ALL
CREEDS ALL AND ALL- ETHNIC BACK
AND THIS IS WHY THE LATINO
COMMUNITY IS SO MUCH IN SUPPORT
OF OUR FRIEND DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING AND WE THINK THAT SENATOR
THE GOOD SENATOR FROM GARDENA
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD THANK
YOU THANK YOU SENATOR GONZALES
SENATOR COMMA FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR ARCHULETA. CENTER COME
LONGER. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
AND MEMBERS GOOD MORNING HI TO
RISE. TO SUPPORT S. C. R. SIXTY
TWO AS VICE CHAIR OF THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATIVE BLACK
CAUCUS TO HONOR THE LATE DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING JUNIOR AND
COMMEMORATE DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR DAY. ON MONDAY
JANUARY SEVENTEENTH. DR KING'S
PEACEFUL TEACHINGS OF CIVIL
DISOBEDIENCE AND COMMITMENT TO
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MOVEMENT. LED
TO A CHANGE OF RACIAL EQUITY AND
EQUALITY FOR AFRICAN AMERICANS.
IN HIS MOST FAMOUS SPEECH. SPOKE
ON THE STEPS OF THE LINCOLN
MEMORIAL R KING SAID. NOW IS
THE TIME TO MAKE REAL THE
PROMISES OF DEMOCRACY. NOW IS
THE TIME TO RISE FROM THE DARK
AND DESOLATE VALLEY OF
SEGREGATION TO THE SUNLIT PATH.
OF RACIAL JUSTICE. NOW IS THE
TIME TO MAKE JUSTICE A REALITY
FOR ALL OF GOD'S CHILDREN. TODAY
MORE THAN EVER DR KING'S WORDS
RING TRUE WE MUST REMAIN
COMMITTED TO PURSUING RACIAL
EQUALITY WITH THE SAME
VIGILANCE. AS THE LATE DOCTOR
CAME IN EVEN THOUGH WE LIVE IN A
PROGRESSIVE CALIFORNIA. WE
SHOULD BE TAKING THOSE WORDS TO
HEART WITH THE WORK THAT WE DO
HERE. YOU KNOW DR KING WAS IN A
LOT OF. MOREHOUSE COLLEGE. IN H.
B. C. U. AND JUST LAST WEEK. H.
B. C. USE ACROSS THE COUNTRY
INCLUDING OUR VERY OWN CHARLES
DREW UNIVERSITY HERE IN SOUTH LA
. RECEIVE THREATS BOMB THREATS
FROM NEO **** FASCIST. DECLARING
THE NEED TO WHITE BLACK PEOPLE
OFF THE FACE OF THE EARTH. SO
THIS WORK THAT WE TALK ABOUT THE
WAYS IN WHICH WE HONOR DR KING.
ARE REAL. THEY ARE INCREDIBLY
REAL. TO THE LIVES IN THE SAFETY
IN THE FUTURE AND THE ABILITY
FOR PROSPERITY FOR ALL. F. E. R.
SIXTY TWO ACKNOWLEDGES THE WORK
OF DR KING AND ENSURES THAT WE
WILL COMMEMORATE HIS EFFORTS
THAT WORK TOWARDS A FUTURE OF
EQUALITY FOR EVERYONE. THIS
RESOLUTION ALSO ACKNOWLEDGES THE
IMPORTANCE OF SERVING YOUR
COUNTRY SERVING YOUR COMMUNITY
SERVING YOUR NEIGHBORS. IN THE
PROGRESSION OF THIS NATION
TOWARDS THE VALUE OF UNITY THAT
WAS SO DEAR TO DR KING. THANK
YOU AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. VOTE ON THIS RESOLUTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR COME LONGER
SENATOR ARCH ALETTA WILL BE
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR WAS SO
SENATOR ARCHULETA- THANK YOU
MISTER TO RISE IN SUPPORT OF.
THE C. R. SIXTY TWO. AS WE HEAR.
SO MANY GREAT THINGS ABOUT
MARTIN LUTHER KING I'D WE'VE ALL
HEARD THE TERM WE'VE SAID IT
TIME AND TIME AGAIN WHEN WE
LOSE. A BROTHER OR SISTER FAMILY
MEMBER A GOOD FRIEND THAT
THEY'RE STILL WITH US HE'S WITH
US RIGHT NOW HE'S WITH US SHE'S
WITH US WE ALWAYS SAY THAT. WHAT
DR MARTIN LUTHER KING I JUST
WANT TO TELL YOU YOU'RE STILL
WITH US. AND IF WE TURN THE
CLOCK BACK I'VE GOT TO TELL YOU
WE LOST YOU A GREAT AMERICAN.
BUT YOU DAVIS LEADERSHIP YOU
GAVE US A VOICE MINORITIES
ACROSS THE BOARD. I RISE AS A
MEMBER OF THE LATINO CAUCUS
SUNRISE IS THE- CHAIR OF THE
MILITARY VETERANS COMMITTEE. TO
SHARE WITH YOU DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING THAT IT WAS YOUR LEADERSHIP
AND YOUR INVOLVEMENT IN THE
DOORS THAT YOU KEPT OPEN. FOR
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR IT'S
BEEN A SLOW STRUGGLE. BUT WE
WOULDN'T BE WHERE WE'RE AT
WITHOUT YOUR VOICE WITHOUT YOUR
MOVEMENT INCLUSION FAIRNESS
EQUALITY. IT IS SOMETHING THAT
WE'RE WORKING ON DR MARTIN
LUTHER KING WE'RE NOT DONE. BUT
I WILL TELL YOU WE'VE MADE
STRIDES RIGHT NOW. MILITARY
ACADEMY WEST POINT. THE NAVAL
ACADEMY HAS TWO SUPERINTENDENTS
AFRICAN AMERICANS BOTH OF A-
THREE STAR GENERALS ADMIRALS.
YOU BECAUSE OF YOUR LEADERSHIP
THAT HAS HAPPENED IN THE
MILITARY MEN AND WOMEN ARE
PROGRESSING BEING PROMOTED AND
ACKNOWLEDGED FOR THEIR WORK
THEIR KNOWLEDGE OR SKILL. AND
THAT IS ACROSS THE BOARD AND ALL
MINORITIES. EVERYONE SHOW WHEN I
THINK OF THE WORK YOU'VE DONE
WITH I THINK THE WORK YOU'RE
STILL DOING. THAT I'VE GOT TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT THIS COUNTRY IS
BETTER BECAUSE OF YOU. YOU WERE
MISSED YOUR GREAT LOSS AND WE
WILL NEVER FORGET YOU. WE WILL
CONTINUE THE STRUGGLE AS
AMERICANS MELTED TOGETHER AND I
THINK THAT'S WHAT YOU WANTED
EQUALITY WHERE NO ONE WOULD LOOK
AT EACH OTHER AND BE ABLE TO SAY
YOU'RE DIFFERENT YOU'RE
DIFFERENT NO. WE'RE ALL GOD'S
CHILDREN AND DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING THANK YOU FOR TO GET THIS
COUNTRY. THANK YOU MR THANK YOU
SIR ARCHULETA CENTER WAS SO.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT ON BEHALF
OF THE LATINO CAUCUS IT'S MY
PLEASURE. TO RISE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS YOU ARE SIXTY
TWO. WHICH COMMEMORATES THE LIFE
AND LEGACY OF THE REVEREND DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING. YOU KNOW ONE
OF THE BIGGEST- TRAGEDIES IS
THAT WE'RE HERE TALKING. TODAY
ABOUT A PERSON THAT IN THE-
NINETEEN SIXTIES WAS A
STRUGGLING FOR EQUAL RIGHTS AND
CIVIL CIVIL RIGHTS. PRACTICALLY
A HUNDRED YEARS AFTER THE
PASSAGE OF THE FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT. THE FOURTEENTH
AMENDMENT IN NINETEEN SIXTY
EIGHT. BASICALLY WAS DESIGNED TO
GIVE AFRICAN CANCER RIGHT AFTER
THE CIVIL WAR. AND BACK THEN
THERE WERE LOTS OF BENEFITS THAT
CAME FROM THAT THE ABILITY TO
VOTE. AFRICAN AMERICANS GOT TO
OWN THEIR OWN LAND AND TRY TO
INTEGRATE AND IN SOCIETY.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THAT WAS AN
ENTIRE MOVEMENT. THAT TOOK A
HUNDRED YEARS THAT WAS
SPECIFICALLY THE NIGHT TO
PREVENT THEM THE VOTE. AND THE-
ABILITY TO INTEGRATE IN SOCIETY
HAVE THE EQUAL OPPORTUNITY. TO
ACHIEVE THEIR DREAMS IS THERE
ANYONE ELSE WHO GAVE RISE TO
CLUE KLUX KLAN. THEY GAVE RISE
TO SYMBOLS OF PEOPLE THAT ONCE
WERE CONSIDERED TREASONOUS AND
ONCE WERE CONSIDERED. TO BE
TRIED FOR TREASON FOR THEIR
CRIMES AGAINST. THE UNITED
STATES IN THOSE SYMBOLS BECAME
PERVASIVE IN THE SOUTH INCLUDING
THE CONFEDERATE FLAG. GROWING UP
I REMEMBER SEEING THE
CONFEDERATE FLAG ON TELEVISION
SHOWS. REMOTE INTO SOMETHING- A
REPRESENTATIVE OF A PLACE
SOMETHING THAT WOULD BE-
REMEMBERED WITH FOND MEMORIES OR
- YOU KNOW POSITIVE- IDEAS
ASSOCIATED WITH A VERY NEGATIVE
CONCEPT MOST OF THOSE WERE VERY
INTERESTING MARKETING- OR OR OR
STRATEGIES TO CHANGE PEOPLE'S
VIEWS ABOUT WHAT THE CIVIL WAR
ACTUALLY WAS AND WHAT IT
REPRESENTED. THERE WERE. THERE
IF YOU ALL HEARD THE TERM
CARPETBAGGER. CARPETBAGGERS WERE
ACTUALLY PEOPLE THAT WENT TO THE
SOUTH TO PROVIDE EDUCATION BUILD
SCHOOLS HELP TO REBUILD THE
SOUTH AND TO HELP BUILD HOUSING
FOR PEOPLE THAT HAVE BEEN
DISPLACED ABOUT BECAUSE THEY
REPRESENTED RECONSTRUCTION THEY
WERE VILIFIED AND OFTENTIMES
TORTURED AND KILLED AND THAT
TERM CARPETBAGGER CAME TO BE
VIEWED AS SOMEBODY FROM THE
OUTSIDE THAT WASN'T WELCOME AND
THAT WAS ORIGINATED IN THE SOUTH
AND IT CAME TO SPEAK. ABOUT WHAT
GREAT ABILITY THEY HAD TO
INSTITUTIONALIZE. NEGATIVE
THINGS INTO POSITIVE THINGS AND
THAT GAVE RISE TO MARTIN LUTHER
KING AND IT WAS. WHEN HE FACED
EVERY MANNER OF DISCRIMINATION
AND THREATS AGAINST HIS LIFE
OFTENTIMES BEING PURSUED AND
SEEN AS A THREAT BY HIS OWN.
GOVERNMENT AND THIS IS A
REMINDER TO US THAT EVEN IF
SOMETHING HAPPENED A HUNDRED
YEARS AGO WERE FIFTY YEARS AGO.
IT DOESN'T MEAN THAT PEOPLE'S
MINDS HAVE BEEN CHANGED AND
THINGS HAVE IMPROVED FOR THE
BETTER AND THAT WE DON'T HAVE NO
LONGER HAVE TO WORRY ABOUT IT.
THE FOURTEENTH AMENDMENT LADIES
AND GENTLEMAN IS STILL UNDER
ATTACK TODAY. IN PLACES LIKE
TEXAS. NATIVE BUT THE CHILDREN
OF FOREIGN BORN. IMMIGRANTS ARE
BEING DENIED BIRTH CERTIFICATES
IN A STATE WITH US SENATOR THAT
WAS BORN OUTSIDE OF THE COUNTRY
. THIS IS- SOMETHING THAT SPEAKS
TO. THE WORK OF MARTIN LUTHER
KING. AND HOW HIS LEG LEAST
LEGACY STILL LIVES ON IT REMINDS
US TO HAVE THE STRAIN FROM THE
BACKBONE AND THE COURAGE. TO
FIGHT. FOR WHAT IS RIGHT FOR
WHAT WE THIS COUNTRY REALLY
STANDS FOR. AND TO NOT HAVE THE
COURAGE TO STAND UP AND FIGHT
FOR WHAT AMERICA IS REALLY ABOUT
. ALTHOUGH THEY NEVER MET IN
PERSON DR KING AND SYSTEMS
CHAVEZ. WE WERE WE WERE
CONNECTED TODAY HE WAS AN
INSPIRATION DR KING INSPIRED
MANY LATINO CIVIL RIGHTS
LEADERS- THE LOTUS WORD
PROCESSORS CHAVEZ- HE ONCE SENT
A TELEGRAM TO SOCIETY JARVIS IN
NINETEEN SIXTY SIX IN SUPPORT OF
LA WAITED ON SUPPORT OF THE
STRUGGLE OF THE STRIKE. IN
SUPPORT OF THE STRUGGLE TO
TELEGRAM SAID AS BROTHERS IN THE
STRUGGLE FOR EQUALITY. I EXTEND
A HAND OF FELLOWSHIP AND GOOD
WILL. AND WISH YOU CONTINUING
SUCCESS TO YOU AND YOUR MEMBERS
THE FIGHT OF THE QUALITY MUST BE
FOUGHT ON MANY FRONTS IN THE
URBAN SLUMS IN THE SWEATSHOPS OF
THE BREEZE FEELS ARE STRUCK
SEPARATE STRUGGLES ARE REALLY A
STRUGGLE FOR FREEDOM DIGNITY AND
HUMANITY. YOU AND YOUR VALIANT
FELLOW WORKERS HAVE DEMONSTRATED
YOUR COMMITMENT TO RIGHTING
GRIEVOUS WRONGS FORCED UPON
EXPLOITED PEOPLE. WE ARE
TOGETHER WITH YOU IN SPIRIT AND
IN THE DETERMINATION THAT OUR
DREAMS FOR A BETTER TOMORROW.
WILL BE REALIZED. THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT. THANK YOU SIR WEST
MANY PASSING WERE GONNA%
RECOGNIZE SENATOR ACTIONS AND
THEN SENATOR BRADFORD WILL
PROVIDE HIS CLOTHES. SENATOR
ACTIONS. MR PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES
THANK YOU I RISE TO JOIN THE
SENATE IN COMMEMORATING AGAIN
THE LIFE AND LEGACY OF RIVER
DART DR MARTIN LUTHER KING
JUNIOR YOU KNOW THIS IS MY
TWELFTH OPPORTUNITY- IN THE
LEGISLATURE TO- HERE AND STAND
IN RECOGNITION THIS GREAT MAN I
HAVE TO TELL YOU I ACTUALLY
THINK THIS YEAR FEELS DIFFERENT.
WHICH IS WHY I CHOSE TOSTAND UP
I IN PREVIOUS YEARS I'VE
LISTENED I HAVEN'T ALWAYS SPOKEN
BECAUSE SO MANY OF MY COLLEAGUES
IN THE ASSEMBLY AND THE SENATE
HAVE BEEN SO ELOQUENT. BUT I DO
THINK THIS YEAR IS DIFFERENT AND
I THINK THAT'S BECAUSE AFTER
YEARS OF OUR SHARING HIS WORDS
IN HONORING THE CAUSES THAT HE
LIVED HE SERVED AND DIED FOR. WE
HAVE A CHANCE TO KEEP MAKING
REAL PROGRESS AND TO MOVE
CLOSER. TOWARDS HIS GOALS AND
WITH OUR VERY OWN HANDS HELP
BEND THAT ARC. TO PUT TOWARDS
JUSTICE. CLOSER TOWARDS JUSTICE
WELL THERE'S STILL SO MUCH TO BE
DONE AS HAS BEEN SAID BY NUMBER
OF MY COLLEAGUES I BELIEVE AFTER
YEARS OF GRINDING WORK TOWARDS
PROGRESS A COUPLE OF EARTHQUAKES
OCCURRED AND OPENED UP NEW
PATHWAYS FOR US TO MAKE. MAJOR
ADVANCES. THE TRAGEDIES OF
GEORGE FLOYD AND BRIANNA TAYLOR
AND SO MANY OTHERS TOO MANY
OTHERS HAVE ALLOWED US TO MAKE
SOME PROGRESS ON REFORMING OUR
SYSTEM OF JUSTICE. THAT WOULD
HAVE BEEN UNTHINKABLE FIVE YEARS
AGO TEN YEARS AGO TWELVE YEARS
AGO. IN JANUARY OF NINETEEN
FIFTY SIX AFTER MOVING HIS
FAMILY INTO A PROJECT IN CHICAGO
TO HIGHLIGHT RACIAL DISPARITIES
IN HOUSING. DR KING WON
CONCESSIONS FROM THE CITY. A
VICTORY THAT HE CALLED THE FIRST
STEP IN A JOURNEY OF A THOUSAND
MILES. AS PART OF A DRESSING
CALIFORNIA'S HOUSING CRISIS WE
HAVE TAKEN OUR OWN STEPS IN
THEIR JOURNEY HOWEVER A
BEGINNING. IN ELIMINATING
BARRIERS FOR PEOPLE OF COLOR
THAT HAVE FACED IN FINDING THEIR
OWN HOMES AND ALLOWING MORE
FAMILIES TO START BUILDING
WEALTH INTERGENERATIONAL WEALTH
pHEIRS. THIS PANDEMIC HAS SHINED
A GLARINGLIGHT ON THE
INEQUITIES IN OUR HEALTH CARE
SYSTEM. AND EVEN AS WE CONTINUE
ADDING MORE CALIFORNIANS TO OUR
HEALTH CARE ROLES WE MUST
ADDRESS THOSE INEQUITIES BOTH
DURING THIS PANDEMIC AND BEYOND.
IN FACT DEEPLY EXAMINING
INEQUITIES HAS BECOME IN PART
BECAUSE OF THESE EARTHQUAKES
BECAUSE OF THESE HAPPENINGS.
THAT I TALKED ABOUT. A CONSTANT
PRIORITY FOR THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SENATE I BELIEVE AND I
THINK IT'S FAIR TO SAY THAT THE
BILLS THAT WE CONTINUE TO
ADDRESS THE SESSION MANY OF THEM
AND BEYOND WILL BE VIEWED
THROUGH A REAL LANDS OF EQUITY.
BUT IT IS UP TO US TO MAKE SURE
THAT CONTINUES TO BE TRUE. SO
YES WHILE THERE IS A LOT OF HARD
WORK YES TO DO. AND OTHER ISSUES
CERTAINLY REMAIN. THIS YEAR
REALLY DOES FEEL DIFFERENT TO ME
. AND I THINK WE HAVE THE
OPPORTUNITY IF WE KEEP WORKING
TOGETHER TO INSURE IT IS
DIFFERENT IT IS DIFFERENT IN
TERMS OF HOW WE CAN TRULY HONOR
THE LIFE AND LEGACY AND
CERTAINLY ADVANCE THAT LEGACY OF
THE REVEREND DR MARTIN LUTHER
KING JUNIOR. BUT IT'S ONLY IF WE
KEEP IT IN FOCUS IT IS ONLY IF
WE MAKE THAT COMMITMENT THAT WE
CAN GROW ON SOME OF THE
SUCCESSES THAT WE HAVE HAD.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT. THANK
YOU SIR ACTIONS SENATOR BRADFORD
YOU'RE RECOGNIZED TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT AND I
WANT TO SINCERELY THANK ALL OF
MY COLLEAGUES WHO STOOD UP THIS
MORNING TO YOU. AT THE EARTH FOX
THEIR WORDS THEIR HOPES THEIR
BELIEFS AND SUPPORT. AND
RECOGNIZING THE LIFE OF DR
MARTIN LUTHER KING. AND I HOPE
WE WALK AWAY WITH JUST NOT
REMEMBERING THE WORDS BUT REALLY
RE DEDICATING OURSELVES TO WHAT
THIS MAN'S LIFE STOOD FOR AND
WHAT HE DIED FOR. DR KING OFTEN
STATED. OUR LIVES BEGIN TO END
THE DAY WE BECOME SILENT ABOUT
WHAT MATTERS MOST. MILITARY
MEMBERS A LOT OF FOLKS LIVES ARE
ENDING. A LOT OF FOLKS ARE
SILENT ON JANUARY SIX THE LOT
FOLKS WERE SILENT ON THE
HOMELESSNESS IN THIS COUNTRY TO
A LOT OF FOLKS WHO ARE SOLID ON
THE RACIAL DISPARITIES THAT
STILL EXIST IN THIS COUNTRY. HE
OFTEN ALSO SAID WE WILL REMEMBER
NOT THE WORDS OF OUR ENEMIES.
BUT THE SILENCE OF OUR FRIENDS.
WE HAVE FAR TOO MANY OF OUR
FRIENDS WERE SILENT. WHEN WE
SHOULD BE SPEAKING UP AND
LETTING THE TRUTH BE HEARD. AND
HE STAYED IT DOESN'T MATTER OW
LONG YOU LIVE IT'S HOW WELL YOU
LIVE HE LIVED ALL OF THIRTY NINE
YEARS IT'S ONLY ONE MEMBER ON
THIS FLOOR YOUNGER THAN THAT.
AND LOOK AT THE IMPACT THAT HE
MADE IN THIRTY NINE YEARS WHAT
ARE YOU DOING MEMBERS. HE ALSO
STATED WE'RE NOT MADE BY
HISTORY. R. WE'RE NOT MAKERS OF
HISTORY I SHOULD SAY WERE MADE
BY HISTORY. FAR TOO OFTEN WE
THINK IT'S ABOUT US IT'S NOT
ABOUT US. IT'S ABOUT SERVICE DR
KING SAID WE CAN ALL BE GREAT.
BECAUSE WE CAN ALL SERVE. I HOPE
WE REFLECT ON MUCH OF WHAT HE
STOOD FOR MUCH OF WHAT HE STATED
THIS WEEKEND AND AS HE WOULD SAY
IT SHOULDN'T BE A DAY OFF BUT A
DAY ON A DAY ON FOR ACTIVISM IN
OUR COMMUNITIES A DAY ON FOR
HELPING END HOMELESSNESS IN THIS
STATE AND THIS COUNTRY. A DAY ON
FOR ENDING THE RACIAL DIVIDE
THAT STILL SEPARATES US A
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM IS STILL
INCARCERATED FAR MORE AFRICAN
AMERICANS LATINOS THAN ANYONE
ELSE IN THIS COUNTRY IT SHOULD
BE A DAY OF SERVICE IT'S A BAR
DATE OF EMPOWERING IN MAKING
SYSTEMIC CHANGE IN THIS STATE IN
THIS NATION OUR- HOUSE FOR A
VOTE ON S. C. R. SIXTY TWO.
THANK YOU SIR BRADFORD SENATORS
RON FILE ITEM FORTY FOUR SCR
NUMBER SIXTY TWO SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN FIVE
ARCHULETA FIVE ADKINS FIVE BASS
FIVE FOUR JUST FIVE BRADFORD HI
BYRON CORTESE FIVE DALLY I DONT
HI TORONTO. A GUNMAN FIVE LASER
. GROVE HERTZBERG HI WITH SO. I
FURTADO ARE YOU JONES I CAN
WATER FIVE LAYERED HI THE MON I
REQUIRE FIVE MELINDA'S. NEWMAN
HI NIELSEN I A SHOW OF BOTH HI
PAM FIVE FOURTEEN TINA I BROUGHT
. FIVE RUBIO FIVE SKINNER HI
AMBER. BY CASKEY FIVE WINNER I
WILL. PLEASE CALL THE APP'S
MEMBERS. HAVE I EVER THERE ARE
SEVERAL LASER GROVE MELINDA'S
AMBERG WELL. I WAS TWENTY EIGHT
NOES ZERO THE RESOLUTION PASSES
MEMBERS WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK
CONGRADULATIONS IN REDFORD AND
CO AUTHORS. MEMBERS WILL RETURN
TO MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS THIS
WILL BE OUR TIME OF THE SESSION
FOR GERMANS IN MEMORY. WE'RE
GOING TO RECOGNIZE- SENATOR
RUBIO. CENTER RUBIO. TENEMENT
GERMAN MEMORY. THE LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE TODAY I
RISE TO A TURN IN THE MEMORY OF
ONE OF THE MOST LEGENDARY
ARTISTS MEXICO HAS EVER PRODUCED
THE CENTRE FERNANDES FOR ALL THE
AND AROUND THE WORLD WHO
APPRECIATED WHAT IS KNOWN IN
MEXICO AS MOSTLY GOT ON CHATHAM
. THE CENTER FOR NON THIS WAS
THE BEST KNOWN VOICE OF THAT
JOHN ROM. YET THE CENTER FOR NON
THIS WAS MORE THAN GENTLE MUSIC.
FOR MORE THAN FIFTY YEARS THE
CENTRE FERNANDES WAS THE VOICE
THE HEART. AND THE SPIRIT OF
MEXICO. WITH HIS INCREDIBLE
POWERFUL VOICE HE EQUALLY
EXALTED THE GREATEST FEELINGS OF
LOVE AND JOY. AS WELL AS THE
SORROWFUL EMOTIONS AND TRAGEDIES
OF THE LESS FORTUNATE. YES IN
HIS LONG CAREER HE SANG FOR
KINGS AND QUEENS PRESIDENTS AND
MANY NOTABLE WORLD LEADERS. BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY HE SANG FOR ALL
OF US HIS PUBLIC ONE WAY OR
ANOTHER EVERYONE SAW THEMSELVES
IN ONE OR MORE OF HIS ICONIC
SONGS HIS SONGS DID NOT PRAISE
RICHES OR POWER. THEY WERE ABOUT
LOVE THEY WERE ABOUT THE HUMAN
SPIRIT THE VALUE OF HARD WORK
HONOR RESPECT AND DIGNITY. AT
THE RATE FOR THE KING ONE OF HIS
MOST CELEBRATED SONGS IS NOW AN
ANTHEM OF SORTS FOR THOSE WHO
LISTEN TO HIS MUSIC. INET THE
VOICE OF A HUMBLE MAN WHO
DESPITE HIS LACK OF MATERIAL
POSSESSIONS AND BY BIRTH BUT HIS
SPIRIT AND THE HONOR OF HIS WORD
THE TEAM HIMSELF ACHING THE
CENTRE FERNANDEZ DID NOT LET
SUCCESS GET IN THE WAY OF
REMEMBERING HIS HUMBLE
BEGINNINGS. HE ALWAYS TOOK THE
TIME TO GIVE THANKS TO HIS
PUBLIC TO HOME HE ALWAYS GAVE
CREDIT FOR ALL HE HAD. AND TO
WHOM HE GAVE HIMSELF FULLY. HIS
CONCERTS WERE PROOF OF THAT THE
CENTRE FERNANDES CONCERTS WERE
VERY UNIQUE. TO THE CHAGRIN OF
HIS MANAGERS AND PROMOTERS BE
SENT THERE WOULD ALWAYS MAKE ONE
THING VERY CLEAR TO HIS PUBLIC
HE WOULD SING UNTIL THEY STOPPED
APPLAUDING HIM. OR WHEN HIS
VOICE GAVE UP AND I PERSONALLY
GOT TO WITNESS THAT AND ONE OF
HIS CONCERTS WHEN THE CONCERT
WAS OVER AND HE YELLED I WANT
ANOTHER HOUR AND I WILL PAY FOR
IT. THE CENTRE FERNANDES
PENETRATING VOICE AND EMOTION
TRANSCENDED TIME. GENERATIONS
BORDER AND JOHN RICE FOR MEXICO.
FOR ALL MEXICANS ABROAD AND FOR
ALL THE FANS AROUND THE WORLD
WHO ADORED HIS MUSIC. THE CENTRE
FERNANDES WILL FOREVER BE THE
KING ELDRIDGE. REST IN POWER.
PERMISSION TO READ IN SPANISH
PLEASE. PERMISSION GRANTED.
THANK YOU DOMESTIC AVAILABLE AN
ADULT ALL YOU NEED OKAY SEVEN
MOST LOSSES YOUNGEST IN NOVEL IN
MEMORY OF THE LAKE AND IDEAL
ECLINICAL V. SENT THE FAN ON
THIS THE CENTER FERNANDEZ
NORTHWEST SOLAMENTE LE MOXIE MO
EX BORN INTO THE LEVEL SIX SEVEN
CHATHAM ONE MUST THINK WENT ON
Y'ALL'S THE CENTER FOR NON
DISPLAY LEVELS IT PUT US ON IT
IS PEOPLE THAT MAKE PEOPLE.
CONSULATE ON BULLS BE SENT BACK
FIVE THOUGH A LOT MORE IS A
SOLID EIGHTY S. YEAH YOU WANT
GET BEAT UP POLICY MOSTLY ONUS
LOS BENEFICIOS MENTAL SUPPORT TO
NOVELS BE SENT THEY CAN POP. UP
AT THE OLDEST MOST LIBERALS.
THEY WANNA MONEY A OLD. LITTLE
MOON DOUBLED OVER SAID IF THEY
HAVE THE WHEN I. OR MUST THEY
WANNA THIS IS BECAUSE- A- SEEING
THE THEM SO ARE THEY- HE'S THE
MANTLE DUSTIN DEAL IN THE AMPLE
. CANADA'S IS PRINTED ON CANADA
. BUT I MAY BE GOING ALL THE ME
HE- AND ALEX YOUR ONLY ONE GET
ALL THOSE. A LOT AMERICA
GATHERED ALMOST ALMOST SEE.
BASIN THE FINANCE BUT I SEE A
SAID ON. A LADY DISCUSS IMPASSE
THING OUT WE SENT THE FED ON
THIS THANK YOU. THE YOU SENATOR
RUBIO WE'RE GOING TO ALAN BY
LAMONT SENATOR AL. MEMBERS I
JUST WANT TO JOIN IN THIS MEMORY
OF BASING FOR NINE THIS SUIT WAS
JUST SUCH AN EXTRAORDINARY
PERSON I JUST WANNA MAKE SURE
BECAUSE HE MAY NOT TELL
EVERYONE. HERE ON THIS FLOOR
BUT- ONE OF OUR COLLEAGUES HAS
HAD THE DISTINCT OPPORTUNITY IN
HONOR OF GETTING TO RECORD
MUSIC. WITH THE CENTER FOR NINE
DAYS AT HIS AT HIS PERSONAL
STUDIO IN MEDICAL- THAT'S THE
CHAIRMAN OF OUR JOINT SELECT A
SELECT COMMITTEE ON CALIFORNIA
AND MEXICO COOPERATION. BEEN
WESSEL SO I JUST TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO TALK TO BEN ABOUT HIS
REALLY SPECIAL EXPERIENCES WITH
WITH THAT WITH THIS LEGEND- YOU
KNOW X. THIRTY SINGER BUT ALSO A
WONDERFUL LEADER SOMEONE WHO
LOOKED OUT. NOT JUST WHO LOOKED
OUT FOR IT FOR THE DISEMPOWERED
TO DISENFRANCHISE AND SPENT A
LOT OF TIME THINKING ABOUT AND
TALKING ABOUT THE PLIGHT OF
IMMIGRANTS HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES AS WELL SO RECIPES
PRESENTED FERNANDES. THANK YOU
SIR ALAN SEVERAL MON FOLLOWED BY
CINDER TROUBLED. CENTER LAMONT
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT ON BEHALF
OF THE LETTER NO CAUCUS I AM
PROUD TO STAND AT THE KNOWLEDGE
THE LIFE OF ONE PER MONTH I.
ENTERTAINERS IN THE LATINO
COMMUNITY DESCENDED CHANTED
FERNANDES OUR BELOVED CHANTED AS
HE WAS COMMONLY KNOWN PASSED ON
DECEMBER TWELFTH AT THE AGE OF
EIGHTY ONE LEAVING BEHIND A
LEGACY AND MUSIC THAT WILL BE
FELT. FOR GENERATIONS TO COME.
YOUR SAID GUEST IF WHEN. BARELY
ESCAPED MEMORY. SICK GIVEN THE-
K. U. S. YOUR- YEAH IOTA. YEAH
CHANT IS SAYING AND HIS FANS
WOULDN'T NORMALLY THINK YOU'D BE
HARD PRESSED TO SING THOSE FEW
LYRICS AROUND ANY LET ME KNOW
AND NOT HAVE. WILL RESPOND WITH
YOUR DADDY YOUR THAT. MANY IN
OUR COMMUNITY DID IT JUST THAT
CRIED WHEN THEY HEARD THE
FAITHFUL NEWS OF HIS PASSING.
THE LET THE NOTE TO LET YOU KNOW
SINCE IT WAS MUCH MORE THAN JUST
A SINGER OR AN ENTERTAINER HE
WAS PART OF OUR FAMILY HE HAS
BEEN PRESENT AT ALL FAMILY
PARTIES INCLUDING IN ST YES.
BAPTISMS AND WEDDINGS AND HIS
MUSIC CAN HELP YOU FEEL AND
EXPRESS EMOTIONS BUT YOU COULD
NOT ALWAYS PUT INTO WORDS.
WHEREVER YOU GO YOU HEAR HIS
MUSIC. FROM THE COOKS AT ALL
YOUR FAVORITE RESTAURANTS TO THE
WORKERS OF CALIFORNIA'S VAST
AGRICULTURE FARM WORKER
INDUSTRY. TO OUR JANITORS AND
MAIDS GARMENT WORKERS DOMESTIC
WORKERS WORKING PROFESSIONALS
AND EVEN IN SOME OF OUR VERY OWN
OFFICES. HIS MUSIC TRANSCENDED
MANY BOUNDARIES HIS ARTISTRY
KNEW NO LIMITS AND HIS
CELEBRATION OF THE MONEY
ACTUALLY SETTLED ON CHANNEL
CULTURE IMPACT. IMPACTED PEOPLE
WORLDWIDE WHEN THE NEWS OF HIS
PASSING SPREAD YOU SAW TRIBUTES
FROM NOT JUST THE LATINO
COMMUNITY BUT THE GREATER
ENTERTAINMENT INDUSTRY INCLUDING
BEYONCE C. AND TONY BENNETT.
THERE'S A VIRAL VIDEO OF COUNTRY
SINGER GEORGE STREET SINGING LA
AT HIS CONCERT UPON HEARING OF
THE PASSING OF ONE OF HIS HEROES
CAN. AND BIG BOY THE HIP HOP
RADIO HOST HONOR CHANTED WHO
SHARED A UNIQUE BOTTLE HE SHARED
A UNIQUE BOND WITH AND WHO HE
SAYS HE SAW PERFORM LIVE FIFTY
TIMES. CENTERS CONCERTS IF YOU
WERE LUCKY ENOUGH TO HAVE
EXPERIENCED ONE WERE
INTERGENERATIONAL CELEBRATIONS
WITH NO BAD SEATS. HE WAS KNOWN
TO PUT ON A FOUR HOUR LONG
PERFORMANCE OFTEN PAYING FINES
FOR GOING OVER HIS ALLOTTED
TIME. AND HE WOULD TELL THE
CROWD THAT SO LONG AS THEY KEPT
CLAPPING AND CHEERING HE WOULD
KEEP SINGING AND SINGING HE DID
. IN THE CROWD NO MATTER HOW FAR
YOUR SEAT WAS FROM THE STAGE HE
HAD AN R. ABOUT HIM THAT MADE
YOU FEEL AS IF HE WAS SINGING
DIRECTLY TO YOU. FOR MANY OF US
CAN HIS MUSIC HELPED US COPE
WHEN WE WENT AWAY TO COLLEGE.
OUR FIRST TIME LIVING AWAY FROM
HOME WITH THE YEARNING FOR SOME
SEMBLANCE OF HOME AND FAMILY IN
A DISTANT PLACE. CHANTERS MUSIC
PROVIDED THAT. LATER IN LIFE
WHEN SANTA STOP TOURING HE WOULD
SPEND MUCH OF HIS TIME AT HIS
RANCH LISTED AS FORTY YEARS.
NAMED AFTER HIS SON NEAR WHAT I
HAD A HEALTHY SCHOOL. OFTEN
MEETING WITH FANS TO STOP BY TO
GET A GLIMPSE OF THE VAST FAMILY
ESTATE. HE BUILT AND HE SHARED
WITH HIS FANS FOR FREE BECAUSE
HE FELT HE OWED HIS SUCCESS TO
THEM. IF YOU WERE LUCKY HE MIGHT
EVEN SING TO YOU AND ONE OF
THESE VISITS. CHANTED WAS LAID
TO REST AT THE RANCH WHERE HE
PERSONALLY AND LOVINGLY RECEIVED
AFFECTION FROM HIS FANS. AND
WHICH HAS BECOME ONE OF THE MOST
VISITED CELEBRITY HOMES IN
MEDICAL. ALTHOUGH THERE ARE MANY
SONGS I COULD QUOTE AND SONGS HE
IS KNOWN FOR INCLUDING ONE OF IT
OF ALL OF IT ILLEGALLY AND I'M
ALSO GOING TO YOUNG AND AN
AMAZING COVER OF MY WAY. ALL
LEAVE YOU WITH THE STATEMENT HE
GAVE WHILE SINGING A COVER OF A
FAMOUS FOR SOME FATAL XIMENES
SONG SIMPLY CALLED GASEOUS.
THANK YOU. GOOD THING WHEN I
PHILOSOPHY YES FACILITY TO BE
SYMPATHETIC ILLEGAL GUINNESS THE
MODEL AND THE MOST THOSE CLASSES
THE CAMPING. LOVE RECALLS ME
BODICE YOUR SUPPORT IS IN
REQUEST. YES NORMALLY NETTLE
SOUP KARENA SUDAH SPITTLE EASES
UP BLOUSE SAUCE IS ALWAYS LOW
WHEN YOU GO TO ANY MAN WHO SAID
HE HAD HAD A DATE IN CS. I ME
SEE CLOSE BUT I CAN BE YEAH GIVE
YOUR MEDICAL CARE VEGAN GOING ON
WITH THAT. NO SO THERE'S ALMOST
BECAUSE THE LOCATION YOU'LL GET
TO WHAT DOES GOOD. AND IS V. SIX
AND A BETA. WELL NOW THAT I'VE
HAD MORE TO AT ADAMSON SO THOSE.
COOL OKAY IN NORTH TOO LONG FOR
YEAH YEAH. SAID A PASS THEY GIVE
US WITH THE- ENORMOUS AND I
LOOKED AND SAW THE OF A THAT TO
BACK LOOKING MUSKY SOON IS THAT
HE- THROUGH RESPECT THOUGH. SU
GOD. IS SOURCE. I HAVE A VERY
PHILOSOPHY IN MY LIFE AND I'VE
ALWAYS BEEN THAT THIS ROLE WE
HAVE TO KINDS OF PEOPLE. RICH
PEOPLE WHO ARE POOR AND POOR
PEOPLE WHO ARE RICH AND THAT.
NOT THE MONEY. BUT YOUR
AFFECTION YOUR RESPECT AND YOUR
APPLAUSE THAT IS THE ONLY THING
THAT I WOULD LIKE TO LEAVE AS AN
INHERITANCE TO MY CHILDREN. SO
THAT THE DAY THAT GOD CALLS ME
THEY'LL SAY WITH HUMILITY. WE
ARE CHILDREN OF THE MAN WHO HAD
TWO GREAT VICES IN LIFE ONE HE
WORKED HARD TO GIVE US.
EVERYTHING HE DID NOT HAVE IN
HIS CHILDHOOD AND THE OTHER HE
LEFT IT ALL ON THE STATE TO BE
ABLE TO TAKE TO THE GRAVE WHAT
HE MOST LOVED IN THIS LIFE. YOUR
RESPECT YOUR LOVE AND YOUR
APPLAUSE AS- YES YES. THANK YOU
TWENTY CAMPUSES CONSISTS. THANK
YOU SIR LAMONT SENATOR OCHO
VOGUE WILL BE FOLLOWED BY
SENATOR WEST SO SENATOR TROUBLED
. THANK YOU MR ARE YOU RISE IN
SORRY. I ALSO RISE TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORY OF A SYNTHESIS THAT NONE
THIS. FOR MANY MEXICAN AMERICAN
FAMILIES THE MUSIC OF THE CENTER
BUTTON ON THIS OR CHANTING. AS
HE WAS KNOWN TO FANS WAS THE
SOUNDTRACK OF THEIR LIVES HIS
MUSIC PLAYED AT BIRTHDAYS
BAPTISMS FUNERALS HE'S IN YET AS
AND EVEN CASUAL IMPROMPTU
BACKYARD GATHERINGS. HIS VOICE
WAS PART OF THEIR HOME AND HIS
LYRICS LIVED DEEP IN THEIR
HEARTS MAKING HIM A STAPLE IN
HOMES ACROSS THE NATION.
ALTHOUGH LESS KNOWN TO ENGLISH
SPEAKING AUDIENCES HE
CONSISTENTLY FILL STADIUMS AND
VENUES THROUGHOUT HIS CAREER. IN
NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT BUT NONE
THIS RECEIVED A STAR ON THE
HOLLYWOOD WALK OF FAME. HE WON
THREE GRAMMYS AND EIGHT LATIN
GRAMMYS AMONG OTHER HONORS HE
APPEARED IN MORE THAN THIRTY
MOVIES AND SOLD MORE THAN FIFTY
MILLION RECORDS. MAINTAINING THE
WRENCH AND A TRADITION BUT NONE
THIS ALWAYS PERFORM WE'RE
WEARING THAT THAT I HAD A CHAT
ROOM. THE CHARTER SUIT SUIT. OF
MARIACHIS HE SANG ABOUT LOVE
HEARTBREAK BETRAYAL AND HIS LOVE
FOR MEXICO. AND WHAT THEY
LEARNED THIS DIDN'T WRITE HIS
SONGS. HE DELIVERED THEM WITH
SUCH EMOTION AND HEART THEY
NEVER BELIEVE BECAME HIS. FOR
MANY. HE EMBODIED WHAT IT MEANT
TO BE MEXICAN. THAT NUMBER IS
REACHED MASSIVE SUCCESS IN THE
SEVENTIES WITH THIS HITS PART OF
IT WHAT ABOUT. WHICH TRANSLATES
INTO RETURN RETURN. THIS SONG IS
ABOUT RETURNING TO A LONG LOST
LOVE. BUT FOR MANY FANS THE LAST
CLUB WAS NOT A PERSON BUT A
PLACE. THEIR HOMELAND OF MEXICO. FERNANDES COULD NOT BUILD HIS
CAREER WITHOUT US FANS
ESPECIALLY THOSE IN CALIFORNIA.
THEY BOUGHT HIS RECORDS IN FIELD
CONCERTS VENUES LIKE THE MILLION
DOLLAR THEATER IN LOS ANGELES.
WHERE MANY GATHERED TO
EXPERIENCE THE CULTURE THROUGH
THE FAMILY EARLY AGENDA SONGS
AND EVENTUALLY BREAK ATTENDANCE
RECORDS I DON'T REMEMBER AND SAY
COMES ACROSS THE STATE. HIS
MUSIC TELL THE BOARD MANY
MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS WERE FEELING. HELP THEM FORGET THEY WERE
MILES AWAY. FROM THEIR HOMETOWNS
AND LOVED ONES AND VALIDATED
THEIR EXISTENCE HERE IN THE
UNITED STATES. IT HIS SONGS
TRAVEL THE PARALLEL TO THE LAGS
MANY MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS WERE
EXPERIENCING. HE SAID ABOUT
PRIDE IN PAIN BUT MOSTLY. FOR
MOST IMPORTANTLY HIS MUSIC
ALLOWED HIS PANTS TO FEEL
VULNERABLE TO CRY OVER LONG.
LOST LOVE EARLY MORNING FOR HOME
. HE OFTEN TWIST FANS AS LONG AS
YOU KEEP APPLAUDING YOUR CHIN
FACEBOOK STOPS IN. TODAY I
CONTINUE TO APOLOGY THANK YOU
FOR THE MUSIC BUT ULTIMATELY
SHAPED A GENERATION OF NOT ONLY
MEXICAN IMMIGRANTS. ALL FANS.
BLOODHOUND COMFORT IN YOUR VOICE
HERE IN THE GREAT STATE THROUGH
YOUR MUSIC FELT SEEN. YOUR
LEGACY WILL CONTINUE TO GROW AS
SECOND AND THIRD GENERATION OF
DINOS CONTINUE TO LISTEN TO YOUR
SONGS BECAUSE IT REMINDS THEM.
ARE THEIR CHILDHOOD. ULTIMATELY
CONTINUES TO BRIDGE GAPS AMONG
THEIR OWN FAMILIES. OR SIMPLY
RESTRICTED EITHER CHECK. THANK
YOU SENATOR TROUBLED SENATOR
MYSELF. I WANT TO THANK ALL THE
MEMBERS FOR THEIR VERY MOVING
SPEECHES HI. I JUST WANT I WANT
TO THANK ALSO- FOR EVERYONE
WANTING TO TURN THIS MEMORY I
WASN'T. CAN I SPEAK BUT I WAS
REALLY MOVED. HI EVERYONE
SPEECHES I WAS VERY DEEPLY MOVED
BECAUSE I THINK- THE CENTER FEB
NINE THIS INSPIRED MANY PEOPLE
TO BE STRONG. TO OVERCOME
CHALLENGES IN LIFE WHETHER IT
WAS POVERTY. OR LEAVING YOUR
COUNTRY OR- OF. THE YOU KNOW OF
LOVE. AND YEAH IT WAS IT'S HARD
TO GO TO ANY EVENT WHETHER IT BE
A MARRIAGE OR A FUNERAL OR KIDS
AND YET I'M NOT HAVE HIS MUSIC
THE FRONT AND CENTER. IN IN IN
THAT EVENT. THE FIRST CHANCE OF
THE FIRST UP TO I GOT A MEDIUM
WHICH HAS HOME AND WHAT WE SENT
THAT WOULD DO IS OPEN UP THOSE
DOORS AND YOU HAD A BIG RANCH
AND HE WAS VERY GENEROUS ABOUT
LETTING ANYONE COME IN AND TOUR
HIS PROPERTY. AND SEE HIS HORSES
AND SEE HIS RANCH. AND WHEN I
FIRST SAW HIM HE WAS SURROUNDED
BY PEOPLE. SIGNING AUTOGRAPHS
TAKING PICTURES. I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYBODY. OF THAT LEVEL OF FAME.
THAT WAS STILL WILLING TO ENGAGE
SO CLOSELY. WITH THE WITH THE-
THE PEOPLE OF HIS COMMUNITY. HE
WOULD JUST OPEN UP THE DOORS AND
LET THEM COME IN. AND I ASKED IS
WHAT'S GOING ON THEY SAID ALL HE
DOES THIS WHEN ONLY WHEN HE'S
HOME. HE ALWAYS DOES. HE'S VERY
GENEROUS VERY WHEN I GOT TO MEET
HIM HE WAS ONE OF THE MOST
HUMBLE PEOPLE. THAT THAT I'VE
EVER HAD THE PLEASURE OF MEETING
I COULDN'T BELIEVE THAT THIS MAN
. WELL WAS IT WAS SO FAMOUS IN
YET SO HUMBLE. MY FATHER WAS A
BIG FAN AND HE PLAYED THE SONG
CALL THE POLICE AND SAY OVER AND
OVER UNTIL I BASICALLY LEARNED.
AND I TOLD HIM THAT I TOLD HIM
THAT MY FANS MY FATHER WAS HIS
BIGGEST FAN HE- FOLLOWED HIM
AROUND HIS CONCERTS. AND- THEN
MY SECOND MEETING HE CALLED ME
AND SAID- I YOU KNOW THERE'S A
CANDIDATE RUNNING FOR PRESIDENT
. THAT HAS OFFENDED ME AND MY
PEOPLE IN MY COUNTRY. AND I FEEL
THAT UNDER HIS PRESIDENCY MY
PEOPLE WILL SUFFER MY COUNTRY
WILL SUFFER. AND I'VE NEVER
REALLY GOTTEN INVOLVED IN
POLITICS POLITICS IS NOT MY
THING. BUT I FEEL DEEPLY
OFFENDED AND I FEEL THAT I CAN'T
JUST STAND BY AND WATCH. AND I'M
GOING TO COMPOSE A SONG AND I
WANT YOU TO HELP ME WITH THE
LYRICS BECAUSE I WANT TO GET HIM
RIGHT. AND HE COMPOSED- THE SONG
CALLED ALGORITHM OR IT'S AN OWN
GOAL TO HILLARY CLINTON AND
CARRIED ON THE HILLARY CLINTON.
AND WHEN IT WAS POSTED AT FORTY
MILLION VIEWS IN THE UNITED
STATES. THAT WAS HIM AND APART
FROM THAT HE CAME IN AND PERFORM
THAT. IN IN SWING STATES IN THE
COUNTRY AND TRY TO DO HIS BEST
TO DEFEND HIS PEOPLE WHAT HE
FELT WAS AN OFFENSE. TO HIM AND
HIS COUNTRYMEN. OF FOREIGN AND
ABROAD AND EVERYONE OF LATINO
DESCENT AND MEXICAN DESCENT. HE
FELT A CERTAIN RESPONSIBILITY
AND- I WAS SO HONORED. TO BE
ASKED TO EVEN CONTRIBUTE A VERY
SMALL PIECE TO THAT. AND IT IS
ONE MEETING HIM REALLY HAS BEEN
ONE OF THE MOST PROFOUND JOYS OF
MY LIFE. AND TO MEET A PERSON
THAT HAS INSPIRED SO MANY THAT
HAS. HELPED SO MANY PEOPLE. GO
THROUGH LIFE WITH SOME- LEVEL OF
JOY. THAT THEY WOULDN'T HAVE HAD
WITHOUT HAVING EVER HAVING HEARD
HIS MAGNIFICENT VOICE IN THIS
WONDERFUL MUSIC AND IT TRULY IS
A TO A SAD DAY I MEAN HE- HIS
HIS DEATH STILL BE MOURNED. AND
MEXICO AND ITS IT'S- A VERY SAD
TIME FOR ALL THE MEXICANS THAT
ARE LOST AN ICON THAT IS
PROBABLY ONE OF THE BIGGEST
STARS IN THE HISTORY OF THE
COUNTRY AND ONE JUST AGAIN THANK
EVERYONE. AND ON THE SENATE FOR
INDULGING US AND ALLOWING US TO-
MEMORIALIZED IN THIS WAY ON THIS
FLOOR ON THIS DAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU SIR WAS SO.
SEEING OTHER MICROPHONES WE
SHOULD BE RECOGNIZED FOR THIS
ITEMS IN A REVIEW IF YOU PLEASE
BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO THEY
CAN. BE PROPERLY MEMORIALIZED BY
THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
MEMBERS IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS. SENATOR ATKINS THE
DESK IS CLEAR. WELL THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT AND- I CLEARLY
HEARTFELT DAY FOR US HERE FOR A
NUMBER OF REASONS SO I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUES AND- WISH
YOU SAFE TRAVELS ON YOUR WAY
HOME AS WE RECOGNIZE- THE MARTIN
LUTHER KING DAY HOLIDAY ON
MONDAY. AND THE NEXT FLOOR
SESSION IS SCHEDULED FOR TUESDAY
JANUARY EIGHTEENTH TWENTY TWENTY
TWO AT TWO PM THANK YOU MR%
PRESIDENT THANK YOU SIR ACTIONS
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY THIS
AFTERNOON AT WHICH TIME THE
GERMAN MOTION WILL BE MADE. WE
WILL RECONVENE TUESDAY AT TWO PM
MEMBERS PLEASE HAVE A SAFE
HEALTHY WEEKEND.